DISTRICT ATTORNEY FANI WILLIS IN
FULTON COUNTY, GEORGIA, IS
LEADING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO REVERSE THAT
STATE'S 2020 RESULT.
A JUDGE HAS JUST RULED THAT
WILLIS CANNOT QUESTION ONE OF
THE SO-CALLED FAKE ELECTORS WHO
TOOK PART IN THE SCHEME.
THE REASON?
WILLIS RECENTLY HOSTED A
FUNDRAISER FOR THAT REPUBLICAN'S
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
LET'S GET TO KARA.
WALK US THROUGH THE RULING HERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE JUDGE DISQUALIFYING FANI
WILLIS FROM INVESTIGATING THIS
ONE FAKE ELECTOR, GEORGIA STATE
SENATOR BURT JONES.
HE WAS ONE OF THE FAKE ELECTORS.
HE IS ALSO RUNNING FOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
THE JUDGE SAYING THAT FANNI
CREATED AN UNTENABLE CONFLICT BY
HOSTING A FUNDRAISER FOR THE
RIVAL FOR THAT POSITION.
FA
FANI WILLIS' OFFICE IS
INVESTIGATING THE FAKE ELECTORS.
IT JUST APPLIES TO JONES.
WHILE SHE CAN CONTINUE TO
COLLECT EVIDENCE AND ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM WITH OTHER
WITNESSES, SHE CANNOT BRING A
CASE AGAINST JONES.
SHE CANNOT CONTINUE TO CALL HIM
A TARGET OF THE INVESTIGATION.
AND THE REPORT BY THE SPECIAL
GRAND JURY CANNOT INCLUDE HIM IN
IT.
YOU KNOW, WHATEVER EVIDENCE SHE
AMASSES, IF THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY THINK COULD BE WORTHY
OF PROSECUTION, THAT WILL GO TO
ANOTHER PROSECUTOR TO MAKE THAT
CHARGING DECISION.
FOR JONES, HE IS NOW FREE FROM
THIS INVESTIGATION UNDER FANI
WILLIS, BUT HER INVESTIGATION
INTO THE OTHER ELECTORS CAN
CONTINUE AND INTO THE BROADER
ISSUES OF THE ACTIVITIES OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> AGAIN, WE'RE TALKING FANI
WILLIS, THE D.A. IN FULTON
COUNTY, AND HER INVESTIGATION,
NONETHELESS, IS STILL CHARGING
FORWARD.
TODAY, ONE OF THE TARGETS OF
TRUMP'S PRESSURE CAMPAIGN,
GEORGIA GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP, IS
TAPING A SWORN STATEMENT FOR THE
SPECIAL GRAND JURY THERE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS
KEY TESTIMONY?
>> YES, HE IS ONE OF THE MOST
HIGH PROFILE WITNESSES SO FAR
APPEARING BEFORE THE GRAND JURY.
NOW, HE IS DOING THIS IN A
RECORDED TESTIMONY TODAY.
IT WILL BE PRESENTED TO THE
GRAND JURY AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE.
THAT ACCOMMODATION WAS MADE
BECAUSE HE IS THE GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE.
HE IS SOMEONE OF INTEREST
BECAUSE HE IS ONE OF THE GEORGIA
OFFICIALS TRUMP REACHED OUT TO
AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION.
TRUMP HAD ASKED HIM IN A PHONE
CALL IF HE COULD CONVENE A
SPECIAL SESSION AND HAVE THE
STATE LEGISLATURE OVERTURN
BIDEN'S VICTORY.
TRUMP ALSO WANTED HIM TO ORDER
AN AUDIT OF THE SIGNATURES ON
THE ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
KEMP REFUSED TO DO EITHER OF
THOSE THINGS.
YOU KNOW, THIS COMES AS THIS
INVESTIGATION IS REALLY RAMPING
UP.
TRUMP'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY, RUDY
GIULIANI, HAS BEEN ORDERED TO
APPEAR NEXT MONTH BEFORE THE
GRAND JURY.
AND ONE OF THE OTHER LAWMAKERS,
THE REPUBLICAN JODY HICE IS
GOING TO BE IN COURT TODAY,
TRYING TO CHALLENGE A SUBPOENA
FOR HIS TESTIMONY.
OF COURSE, THE OTHER STATE
ELECTORS, APART FROM JONES, WILL
BE APPEARING THIS WEEK BEFORE
THE GRAND JURY.
>> KARA SCANNELL, A MOVING
INVESTIGATION AND A LOT OF
PARTS.
THANK YOU FOR STAYING ON TOP OF
IT.
>> WITH US NOW POLITICAL
REPORTER FOR THE ATLANTA JOURNAL
INSTITUTION PATRICIA MURPHY AND
FORMER SENIOR INVESTIGATOR FOR
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE JOHN
WOOD, HE'S ALSO RUNNING FOR
SENATE IN MISSOURI AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
BRIAN KEMP, THE GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA, WHERE DOES HE FIT INTO
THIS SORRY?
>> SO WE KNOW HERE IN GEORGIA
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP CONTACTED GOVERNOR BRIAN
KEMP ON MORE THAN ONE OCCASION,
ON ONE OCCASION HE ASKED THE
GOVERNOR TO CALL IN A SPECIAL
SESSION TO REVERSE THE RESULTS
OF THE 2020 ELECTIONS, TRUMP HAS
OBVIOUSLY CONTACTED MULTIPLE
GEORGIA OFFICIALS, INCLUDING
SECRETARY OF STATE BRAD RATCHETS
BER
-- RAFFENSPERGER.
WE KNOW ALL ABOUT THAT CALL
BECAUSE IT WAS TAPED BUT WE KNOW
LITTLE ABOUT WHAT TRUMP SAID TO
BRIAN KEMP.
WHAT IS THAT THE TESTIMONY WILL
GET INTO TODAY.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID A
DEEP DIVE INTO THE INVESTIGATION
AND NOTED THAT FANI WILLIS HAS
USED RACKETEERING IN THE PAST IN
MANY OF HIS PROSECUTIONS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IF SHE WERE
TO USE THAT HERE, RACKETEERING?
JUST BROADLY DEFINE IT AND HOW
WOULD IT APPLY TO THIS SPECIFIC
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, IT WOULD MEAN SHE WOULD
HAVE TO FIND THAT THERE WAS A
CORRUPT ORGANIZATION OF SOME
SORT AND THAT, OF COURSE, DONALD
TRUMP WAS THE LEADER OF THAT.
SO, YOU KNOW, EARLY REPORTS WERE
THAT SHE WAS FOCUSED VERY MUCH
ON THE SO-CALLED FAKE ELECTORS
WHICH WERE THE TRUMP ELECTORS
WHO CAST THEIR VOTES IN STATES
THAT TRUMP LOST, BUT THIS
INTERVIEW OF GOVERNOR KEMP
SUGGESTS THAT SHE'S LOOKING AT A
LOT MORE THAN THAT AND IN
PARTICULAR FOCUSING ON DONALD
TRUMP'S CONDUCT AND THE CALLS
THAT HE MADE TO TRY TO GET STATE
OFFICIALS TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME
OF THE ELECTION.
>> AN ORGANIZATION, WHAT WOULD
THAT HAVE TO ENTAIL LEGALLY
SPEAKING?
HOW MANY PEOPLE INVOLVED?
WHAT LEVEL AND IN WHAT TYPES OF
COMMUNICATION?
>> YEAH, SO I'M ACTUALLY NOT AN
EXPERT ON GEORGIA LAW.
IF IT'S FANI WILLIS IT WOULD
HAVE A GEORGIA LAW CHARGE RATHER
THAN A FEDERAL CHARGE AND I'M
NOT AN EXPERT IN GEORGIA LAW BUT
ESSENTIALLY SHE HAS TO SHOW THAT
TWO OR MORE PEOPLE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER AS PART OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS CORRUPTED
ESSENTIALLY.
>> PATRICIA, YOU ARE DOWN THERE.
WHAT'S THE SENSE OF HOW FAST,
HOW QUICKLY THIS IS ALL MOVING?
>> SO WE'VE SEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PARADE OF GEORGIA OFFICIALS COME
IN FRONT OF THE SPECIAL GRAND
JURY.
WE'VE SEEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE STATE, OBVIOUSLY BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER, A NUMBER OF STATE
LAWMAKERS.
WE HAVE SEEN A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
FANI WILLIS SAYS SHE WILL HALT
THIS INVESTIGATION IF IT GETS
TOO CLOSE TO THE 2022 ELECTION,
THAT GIVES US A SENSE THAT THIS
COULD STILL BE GOING ON THROUGH
THE FALL.
SHE SAID SHE WON'T END IT PRE
MATURING JUST TO COOPERATE WITH
AN ELECTION DATE.
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHEN
THIS IS GOING TO WRAP UP BUT IT
CERTAINLY DOES FEEL LIKE SHE IS
REACHING A CRESCENDO OF THE
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY HERE IN THE
GOVERNOR, HE IS A VERY BIG
WITNESS, THEY'VE SCHEDULED IT
VIDEOTAPED TESTIMONY TO WORK
WITH HIS SCHEDULE BUT HE IS
ABSOLUTELY THE HIGHEST RANKING
OFFICIAL WE HAVE SEEN SO FAR AND
IT'S IN A PROCESS OF GETTING
SORT OF TO THE HIGHER UP
OFFICIALS AND THEN THE CLOSEST
TO FORMER PRESIDENT PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> JOHN, IF CHARGES ARE BROUGHT
HERE, AS YOU CORRECTLY NOTE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GEORGIA LAW,
GEORGIA CHARGES, STATE CHARGES,
WHAT WOULD THE LIKELIHOOD OF
CONVICTION BE?
OUR ELLIE HONING POINTS OUT IT'S
A HIGH BAR AND THERE ARE LOT OF
STEPS IN BETWEEN CHARGES AND
ULTIMATE CONVICTION, INCLUDING
PERHAPS TRYING TO MOVE THIS TO
FEDERAL COURT SO WHAT DO YOU
SEE?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY GETTING A
CONVICTION IS A HIGH BAR BUT
PROSECUTORS KEEP THAT IN MIND
WHEN THEY MAKE THE CHARGING
DECISION.
SO GENERALLY PROSECUTORS DON'T
LIKE TO BRING CHARGES UNLESS
THEY FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THEY
CAN CONVICT A JURY BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT FAN REWILLIS
WILL GET TO THAT POINT BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING SHE WILL KEEP
IN MIND BEFORE SHE MAKES A
CHARGING DECISION.
>> SHE HAS BEEN CHASTISED AT
LEAST SOME FOR SOME POLITICAL
ACTIVITY SORT OF SEPARATE FROM
THIS.
EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
FANI WILLIS IS AN ELECTED
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIAL AS THE DA IN
FULTON COUNTY.
SHE HELD A FUNDRAISER FOR
CHARLIE BAILEY, THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE RUNNING FOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
SHE ALSO HAS NOTIFIED THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, STATE
SENATOR BERT JONES THAT HE IS A
TARGET TO THIS INVESTIGATION.
HE IS VERY CLOSE TO DONALD TRUMP
AND WORKS TO SERVE AS A FAKE
ELECTOR HERE IN THE STATE.
SO SHE HAS HELD A FUNDRAISER FOR
THE OPPONENT OF SOMEBODY WHO IS
A TARGET OF HER INVESTIGATION.
THE JUDGE SAID IT MAY NOT
TECHNICALLY BE ILLEGAL, BUT IT
WAS SORT OF A WHAT YOU WERE YOU
THINKING MOMENT.
HE SAID THAT TO HER IN OPEN
COURT.
WE WERE THERE.
WE HAVE NOTED THAT THAT WAS
REALLY A PUBLIC DISPLAY OF
CHASTISING THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
HER CAMP HAS SAID THAT WAS A
FUNDRAISER FOR THE PRIMARY
ELECTION NOT THE ELECTION
AGAINST BERT JONES BUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE
AGREEING WITH THE JUDGE, WHAT
WERE YOU THINKING?
THIS IS A HIGH PROFILE
INVESTIGATION.
SHE IS AN ELECTED DEMOCRATIC
OFFICIAL AND SAID SHE'S DOING
THESE TWO THINGS SEPARATELY.
I DON'T EXPECT HER TO HOLD
ANOTHER FUNDRAISER FOR CHARLIE
BAILEY IN THE FUTURE.
>> PATRICIA AND JOHN, THANKS TO
BOTH OF YOU.